I'm pissed off if the attackers are
never found how will you be able to heal
I don't know let's just hope that they
are you know what I'm saying
like let's not go there yet Jessie small
it breaks his silence in his first TV
interview detailing his attack in
Chicago that has been called a hate
crime and there is no doubt in your mind
what motivated this attack I could only
go off of their words
I mean who says in pipe this maggot
country ties a noose around your neck
and pours bleach on you and this is just
a friendly fight as et previously
reported Jesse told the Chicago PD he
was on the phone with his manager
Brandon Z more during the attack on
January 29th his manager recalls clearly
hearing both racial and homophobic slurs
I see the attacker and asked and he said
this maggot country punches me right in
the face so I punched his ass back then
I looked down and I see that there's a
rope around my neck which I had it was
so fast authorities located surveillance
cameras showing two persons of interest
in their investigation while Jesse says
he did not get a good look at his
attackers he's confident he can identify
them have you seen that image and do you
believe that they could possibly be the
attackers I do what is it about their
their size or what why do you feel that
they could possibly be because I was
there
for me when that was released I was like
okay we're getting somewhere I don't
have any doubt in my mind that that's
good the Empire star also addressed his
frustration with inaccuracies about the
incident I've heard that it was a date
gone bad which I so resent that
narrative I'm not gonna go out and get a
tuna sandwich out a salad to meet
somebody that's ridiculous and it's
offensive and cleared up why he did not
initially turn over his phone to police
they wanted me to give my phone to the
tech for three to four hours I'm sorry
but I'm not gonna do that why because I
have private pictures and videos and
numbers my partner's number my family's
number my castmates number of my friends
numbers my private emails my private
songs my private voice memos one thing
Jesse wants more than anything real
justice after his attack I want that
video found so badly because for the
probably four reasons number one I want
them to find the people that did it
number two I want them to stop being
able to say alleged attack number three
I want them to see that I fought back
and I want a little gay boy who might
watch this to see that I fought back
[Music]